what's going on everybody and welcome to
part three of the JavaScript basics
tutorial series in this video what we're
gonna be doing is animating our blobs on
the canvas itself so let's go ahead and
jump into it so the first thing we're
gonna do is we'll just comment these out
here actually we're gonna comment all
three of them and the next thing I want
to do is basically the way that we're
going to animate something on the canvas
is using a built in called set interval
and set interval is going to take two
parameters that's going to be the
function that you actually want to run
and then the milliseconds between each
time you want to run it so in our case
we want to run the blob function so we
would just run you know blob and we
would want to run that every 100
milliseconds but we want to move so
right now blob is gonna stay in place so
so for example we might you know we
would take this paste that in but that's
not gonna move its gonna it'll keep
interval
but it's gonna stay in the same location
so we actually want to update that
location so the way that we're gonna do
that is first we're gonna need to set
two new values so we're gonna say let X
and we'll start that at 50 and then
we'll say let Y whoops typo will start
that as well at 50 so let because we
want to actually change the value here
like we don't want that to be constant
so once we've done that the next thing
that we might think is we would come
down here and we would say X plus plus
and then Y plus plus and for the life of
me I can't remember if we've talked
about plus plus I'm gonna talk about it
again plus plus is identical to saying
like plus equals one and if we say X
plus plus or X plus plus equals
one that's identical to saying x equals
x plus one sorry if I've repeated that
twice because I've also written it in
the text base so I can't remember if
I've covered that or not that's like one
of those things that I've covered like a
million times in Python 2 and I just
forget about it but anyways that's what
that's all it's happening so every time
that runs it's just gonna add one to X
so now after this function runs it's 51
and then after Y run Y runs or after
this function 1 runs and we get to this
line why we we add 1 to Y so now what we
want to do it's just run this function a
bunch of times
so rather than being a we have one more
thing we need to do so because we're
calling this X in this X and this wine
this wine we actually are kind of
replacing x and y locally inside of this
function because we're using them as
parameters so I actually want to change
this to be X Lok X Lok so we're still
passing X&Y into here so we will need to
change this to X & Y naught T but why
but then locally rather than referring
to x and y as X&Y we actually just want
referred on that as X lo cuz actually
all we're doing is referring to the
value we're not actually passing the
object into there okay so when we pass x
and y like if we left this as x and y we
actually would have changed our name
space a little bit these exit x's and
y's these these variables anyway they
would not be modifiable anymore so we
need to change these because these are
actually just temporarily used to take
in the parameters that we pass in here
so we're gonna change this to X look in
this to white look but then down here
when we say X + + + y + + we're not
referring to the x + y that was passed
here so all we pass really was the value
when we say this down here we're
modifying these up here these variables
here so okay cool so we think we're
ready we're set the owner of
we're ready to run this thing so we save
that and run in the browser and what the
heck nothing's happening so then I start
wondering like is set interval working
or is blob like which one is not working
that I do set interval wrong or that I
do blob wrong right because I'm kind of
in the dark here like with Python I'm
kind of to the point where I pretty much
know and expect how things work well
with JavaScript there's all these like
new little intricacies that are just
unfamiliar to me I've never ran into the
issues like this you know so I'm sure I
have to learn all these things all over
again
so hopefully you're enjoying learning
them with me so so the first thing I
would do when this is not happening the
way I expect is like okay well let's
forget about setting the interval
because we expect set interval to run
the blob function a handful of times
right so let's just run the blob
function a handful of times right so
sort of step one to test this bad boy
and you should be able to see it but you
could also see in yours it clearly moved
right it it didn't get rid of the
original blobs but that's okay it's
helpful to us because we can literally
see that it moved so what gives what's
what's the problem so basically I had to
search set interval and figure out what
was going on and like read a bunch as
posts and stuff and what happens is when
you send in a function with parameters
the parameter has become a local to the
set interval it so it becomes local to
the timer function itself so so now
you're like well that's screwed up
because well first of all I don't I'm
not sure why that's happening I think
that's kind of lame because help like
this is so much cleaner than what we're
gonna have to do but the workaround is
to just make a I'm gonna call it a
throwaway function I don't know if
there's a particular name for these in
JavaScript but it's a throwaway function
literally rather than sending in blob
I'm going to send in off just function
empty parms and i'm just going to create
the function inside of here
it's I think that's all my way around it
I don't know there's there might be
something better and if you know a
better way please feel free to leave
leave it below so anyways so now what we
might think is well what we still can't
just like sending in blob here is not
going to make any difference so if we
send in blob here and do this we can
test it but I don't believe that will
change anything for us right so it's
still not working because it's actually
just gonna draw a blob in the same
location every single time oh well
definitely let's at least get it
somewhere right I just already knew it
was gonna fail oh no it's actually
working
what the heck I really thought that if
you passed this in here you would have
to modify these outside but I guess not
see isn't that screwy I don't like that
anyway I was pretty sure what we were
gonna wind up needing to do is remove
X&Y here and put them in here like that
which if this doesn't achieve the safe
result when I run it I quit oh thank god
okay so it's the only way that works as
well and I was pretty sure that was how
we were gonna have to do it we're gonna
have to take these values out of the
function but I guess that doesn't really
make any sense because to JavaScript
it's just running it just gets to this
function it's like okay we got to run
this stuff now so actually we can leave
those right in there and I guess that
makes sense I guess
hashtag JavaScript Oh so anyway alright
so that was fun like I said I'm a
JavaScript new so we have a couple of
other issues the most egregious issue
that I think we can solve right away is
now that we have done our debugging like
this is not how we intend the blobs you
know we don't want them sliding across
like a piece of chalk instead what we
want is a new one like to be cleared
every single time so the object we have
a few
options the probably the most reasonable
choice is to just clear the rectangle
every time so or just Bailey clear the
entire canvas and we do that with clear
rect now later you can clear like
specific areas and even clear rect
allows us to clear really specific areas
but because we're gonna draw a lot of
stuff to the screen anyways I'm just
gonna clear the whole thing every single
time and if we start having performance
issues for a reason by doing that then
we can start to address well how could
you know will individual smaller clear
is actually saved us any time first of
all and then how might we do that but
for now we're just gonna wipe the entire
slate clean and then redraw into the
user that's viewing it'll happen
so fast they won't even know what
happened so so what we wanted to say is
context dot clear rect and here is where
we pass basically you know you're gonna
pass to coordinates you're gonna pass
the the starting coordinate and then the
ending coordinate and it basically just
makes a rectangle to that size so the
start is just zero zero and then all the
way to canvas dot uh width and then
canvas canvas dot height and and that's
it we're gonna just clear all of that
away so we save that run that and as you
can see we've got this beautiful blob
now just simply moving on its way and it
looks a little jittery still but that's
probably actually more so because of
this like we could probably like we're
up it's basically running at ten frames
a second okay so so we can drop that a
little bit and then hopefully that would
be a little swell it's not quite smooth
I'm also on a VPS so this this may never
look good but I'm just now now I'm just
curious the video is pretty much over
you're free to get the heck out of here
if you want but I just kind of want to
so rather than so one cool thing about
the canvas is you can do things in
decimals so rather than moving an entire
one we can actually move point two so
I'm just gonna do that I'm just just got
try I'm just gonna try I'm just curious
yeah it's still a little jittery it's
probably because I'm on a VPS though so
what's the next issue that's our problem
well the problem is the next major
issues that our blob just simply has no
idea about boundaries it just should off
the screen so in the next tutorial what
we're going to be talking about is
conditional so how can we keep the blob
on the screen and effectively just kind
of have it bouncing around on the screen
so that's what we're going to be doing
in the next tutorial quick shout-out to
my channel members who've been here for
over six months that's a long time got
Alexis Wong Bingley Metanoia Reginald
Roberts and Louise thank you guys very
much for your support you guys are
amazing people okay
that's it I'll see you guys in the next
video